relationships as we saw in this film can
be tricky old ones new ones evolving
ones mother-daughter relationships and I
think when you add in a creative
endeavor and a business relationship it
could possibly get even trickier so tell
us how did you to navigate that well it
actually wasn't quite so tricky I had
written a few drafts of this script and
she knew that I was working on it and
had encouraged this particular idea and
I gave it to her and and she gave me
some notes and we we worked on the
script a bit and then I asked if she
would produce the movie and you know we
kept going and kept going and and it was
a really a great working relationship I
think yeah you get to know if you never
see each other again but no it was great
it was really good it is a question
that's come up a lot because people have
tricky relationships with their parents
mother-daughter things but we would have
never entered into this if we had one of
those kind of relationships and yeah it
was really smooth and I'm so proud of
her I think she did a great job and I
was happy for her she did so obviously
you grew up in Hollywood you grew up on
your parents movie sets yeah and then
you went to college to study literature
correct I did yeah okay so how did you
find your way back into filmmaking or do
you feel like you ever really left I
don't feel like I ever really left
because you know my mom was making
movies while I was in college and I was
on her sets and I grew up seeing my
parents make films and I give reason I
actually studied something different was
because I knew I wanted to do this so as
soon as I closed those books I came
right back to LA she actually went to
USC for a year or she got accepted into
the screenwriting program and we were
really proud of her it's very hard to
school to get into and we didn't happen
to have any connections actually she
just we didn't even know she was
applying she just applied God and it was
great but she came home one day and she
said they honestly don't know any movies
before star wars I'm
I hear that a lot yeah you said you know
I'm just I feel I should say literature
and I kind of know some of this stuff is
it getting any easier to get the
feminine voice up on screen you know I I
imagine you've maybe fought a battle or
two over the years but now that you see
how we going down that same road I mean
do you do you feel like that's getting
any better will she have an easier time
maybe of telling strong feminine stories
I don't think so don't think so it's a
simple answer I don't think it is easier
it was much easier 20 years ago 15 years
ago and ten years ago it's harder I mean
everybody in this room knows that it's
hard to know there aren't very many
human stories being told about people
and relationships and yeah it's hard
it's hard to get one made yeah and I
think with a female lead it's really
hard that's why all these wonderful
actresses are going to TV so talk about
the writing and the casting I mean did
you sort of write it with Reese's voice
in mind well you know when I was writing
and I was writing I'm a first-time
filmmaker
I was making an indie movie so I didn't
necessarily think Oh Reese Witherspoon's
probably gonna be in this movie but you
know you always hope and you picture
movie stars generally while you're
writing I do at least there's not
necessarily even living ones just people
that help you get into the voice of a
character or genre and so yeah she
definitely wandered in and when when we
were done she I just thought you know
why not let's send it to her she was
really the perfect person for this part
and I was yeah and I think she could
relate to this character and it came
really naturally and easy to her and she
came on board with us right away which
was great and she was um you know just
that was an amazing thing for me and
really thrilling and it still is and
then the rest of the casting process the
three boys and two of them it was their
first film and it was just we really
really carefully searched and found the
right person for the job for each of
these roles and I noticed that your dad
was your second she was the second unit
director he he helped me out a little
bit on that yeah he was a very small
movie a day by lunch he was done
so it's nice it was still a family
affair yeah well you know those shots
are so important especially in an indie
movie every you know you don't have a
chance to redo anything and I just
thought you know who will help me and do
this really super well yeah let's see
who could I call yeah did you have a
typical you know short schedule in D
budget all that I mean yeah 30 days yeah
Wow so Nancy were you um were you on set
were you an active producer were you
just sort of there when she needed you
know sort of mom can you help me fix
this or no I really was the producer you
know and I was really the nuts and bolts
person I mean I wasn't the line producer
but sure um yeah I was really there yeah
all day every day yeah especially on an
India producer wears a lot of hats
yeah and covers a lot of territory and
she was both a creative producer and
yeah and I never made a movie on this
scale before so by the time we started
shooting I got it but the beginning of
prep I didn't get it so things I would
say where's the this person or how did
they say we don't have that person that
doesn't exist you know that's gotta
change the way you think without I want
to do it again me do that again
but no I don't know I did learn a lot I
did learn a lot and and it is
interesting when you don't have time to
get what you need what you can come up
with I'll bet a lot of creative problems
yeah it happened yeah it was in Toronto
part was interesting but not so
interesting that I want to do that but
you know used to do on any movie of any
size you know they always say the Billy
Wilder always said in the car going home
he always figured out how to how he
should have shot it yeah so that happens
if you've had three days to do a scene
or you have like in our case you know a
third of a day you wish you you always
think oh why didn't we just you know I'm
so proud of the movie though I think
it's a it's an amazing feed all of these
young people or any age person that
makes these movies on these tight
schedules without a lot of money yeah
the actors are so spectacular
someone like Reese Witherspoon who makes
big big suit
movies comes in it rolls up her sleeves
and just doesn't mess around never a
minute late everybody knows their lines
everybody works so hard the camaraderie
and all of that that I would love to
duplicate that was great yeah yeah well
help me thank thanks a lot thank you